In the early '90s, CD-ROM's burst onto the scene starting first with computers
and then actually moving to consoles. Of course, with it became larger asset
sizes as well as increased load times. See, the medium of actually getting data
off of a CD-ROM was much slower than cartridge counterparts were for earlier
game systems. This means for the first time in history, game developers are
actually forcing users to stare at a very, very boring screen that just told
them content was loading. This of course was because the assets took time to
get into memory and they weren't being streamed of disc fast enough. More
importantly, game developers didn't really have the proper knowledge of how to
work around this problem. Most of the architectures back then were
single-threaded, which meant all the file iO was actually synchronous, or
blocking, so they had to come up with very, very tricky mechanisms to load data
and render that little UI. Now for grits we run into the same problem. If a
user is on a very, very slow connection, it's actually going to take a lot of
time to stream that data in. For our purposes we actually employ an
asynchronous asset loading methodology. Which means we can actually render
things to the screen, while actually pulling data in from the net. And that's
what we're going to talk about here in just a bit.